[Music]
there's a woman
who suddenly found herself very wealthy
after her grandma passed away and left
her everything oh i need some [ __ ] like
that but now her dad who abandoned her
at age 13
coming back is claiming that he deserves
a share no way get out of here but then
the grandma specifically left it for her
right
and the dad's not by a lot i mean it's
not blood related to the blood related
oh so this is his mom this is his mom
hey but you leave at 13. yeah but what's
the will say yeah that's that that will
get to it right the second i tell you
that the article's over
so this woman has found herself in a
difficult moral dilemma after her
grandma passed away and has left
everything in her will
although it's not you know unusual for
grandparents to do that like we've
already discussed and found out this is
the father's mother and the father had
abandoned this family because at age 13
uh it was discovered that he was having
an affair with another woman
now
he ended up loving this other woman
mourin chose to go
separate ways and even ended up having a
family with us you don't get no monies
then yeah yeah i'm sorry man
so she says she says when i was 13 years
old my mother found out my father was
having an affair and he got the other
woman pregnant my dad confessed he was
in love with the other woman and wanted
to leave my mother
she obviously heartbroken she was
obviously heartbroken didn't know what
to do as we had moved to a new state
with my father um for work and she had
no family around my father dropped us
like a bad habit and he attempted to
keep a relationship with me but
ultimately his new family was his
priority because of him they're probably
way more fun though like way more
yeah she said tough to understand for a
13 year old but whatever if he didn't
want me i wasn't going to need him so my
mother and i moved on what a g the only
way we were able to do to move on was
with the help of my grandmother my
father's mother she always loved us and
was appalled with what her son had done
to us he stopped seeing her as well for
the most part
plot thickened that was dope though to
take in the in-law yeah the end that's
[ __ ] dope that's the g especially
when you recognize that something like
kind of [ __ ] up super shady did you
say what state this is or where where
this is yeah i didn't say what state
this is but uh irrelevant all right
we're just trying to pick uh do you see
west virginia or california what do you
guys think saudi arabia oh
yeah
i agree with this
it makes it really spicy if it's a saudi
arabia oh
[ __ ] this took a whole new layer because
you know there might be like executions
involved
the risk of the risk risk is crazy
relevant
let's do something that we don't know
like madagascar or something there's a
rule in the acting world if or in
theater if you get really close to your
scene partner you either got to kiss
them or you got to kill them you got to
make it interesting otherwise you've got
no reason to be that close to that
person like close in real life like
physically close physically close
over the years the woman and her mom
became increasingly close with the
grandma often spending special occasions
and holidays together while her dad was
quote unquote nowhere to be found
unfortunately the years caught up with
her and she developed colon cancer
advanced late stage her decline was
rapping and within a few months she was
in a hospital no
oh no days before she passed she asked
me to call her son to come see her as
she knew her time was coming he'd only
been to see her a couple of times since
she had gotten sick and when he came by
i was visiting as we did every few days
and he acted like i was some random
person
grandma asked him to come back tomorrow
but he said he'd come back in a few days
and she passed four days later without
him coming back despite my calls and
texts to come he sounds like a loser
yeah she went peacefully with me and my
mom by her side and that was hard and i
missed her every day she was my guardian
angel most of my life and i know she
continues to watch over me now here
comes the the facts
after the funeral and everything took
place the woman and her mom were
contacted by her grandmother's lawyer
who revealed that she had in fact left
her home and two hundred thousand
dollars to her in her will well yeah i
had no idea she did that but in the will
there was a note to me from her that
said you are worth it love grandma she's
amazing what a great what a great letter
also in her will she left my father
exactly one dollar
that's a big dick that's nice i like it
i like inheritance and when he found out
that's the fadeaway shot yeah
at the buzzer that's that that's a half
court three
that's a steph curry yeah that's a staff
curry like
or that's like you're already up by 30
and you still are trying to go hard in
the pain
you dunk it on the whole team nice so
she leaves one dollar as his inheritance
and when he found out he went ballistic
blowing up my phone all the time
demanding i give him his house and his
money what a piece of [ __ ]
this guy's a selfish
[ __ ] his new wife and his son were
messaging me a lot and his son was
writing on social media that i had
manipulated my grandmother oh dude
set the whole family on fire [ __ ] i hope
it's not what i think it is what do you
think it is i think that even though the
dad wasn't around he might have been
taking care of the grandma and then
sending the money
and no one knew and then so he's like
that's [ __ ] my money that i need back
i don't think it was that okay i feel
like the grand the grandma seems like a
good person i feel like she would been
hey you know he was financially
supporting me i mean obviously yeah it
happened i don't think she would have
done that to her on sunday i don't think
he would leave him a dollar a dollar she
would have left him nothing yeah that's
like leaving like your server a penny
you know
the service is really bad exactly that's
that's a choice that's true it's just
some people you know you just don't know
you know
eventually the woman's father apologized
for his behavior and explained he was
under a lot of stress because he's in
debt and was expecting a windfall from
his mom to help cover the bills and send
his son to college leading her to feel
bad and question whether she should
share the money [ __ ] no no no [ __ ] that
dude that's where moral dilemma i can
her story sounds very similar to mine
like uh father left at 13 uh had an
affair very [ __ ] similar had a
separate family all this stuff right so
you got a house in 200 000 oh that's the
thing i wish so i didn't have a grandma
that like took me under her wing or
anything like that but if i was in her
shoes i'd be like
you get
one dollar [ __ ] because that's what
you're worth
you know it's like what's the she
doesn't know him [ __ ]
but then he comes back and he's just
like oh you know i'm sorry but like you
know i'm mad and dead that's your fault
that's your problem bro he made those
choices especially if he was banking on
it then yeah he's probably making worse
choices yeah for real
manipulators like they know how to like
[ __ ] with people they know how to like
pull my heart strings in yeah i don't
know so everybody's unanimous on the
same board right if you have a daughter
and you leave when that girl is 13 and
you start a whole new family
i don't know bro here's the thing in
that in the scenario you created where
he secretly is helping his mother i
think at least
he has a relationship with his daughter
that
he could hate his ex-wife yeah but like
his daughter is a kid right but he's
abandoned her yeah what did she have to
do with it so if he's decent enough to
take care of his mother he would
probably be decent enough to keep a
somewhat healthy relationship with his
daughter but it seemed like he pieced on
every accord yeah so this needs a
scumbag actually he has a new family he
sounds very selfish he sounds like he
thinks about himself
he bought too many non-fungible tokens
and like that's it he shouldn't about
the nft man
we told him dude he needs to visit the
daughter
slip on like a banana peel and then sue
them for the house
then that way you can get the house that
way damn slip on a banana
so he's uh he he uses the mario kart
method
to win back the money melted butter is
is more original i think yeah banana
peel the quartz are going to [ __ ]
stop that you go take a stick butter put
in the microwave put in a cup and you're
like throw it on there on the black top
you got to put it in the cup before you
put in the microwave
so otherwise you have to take out the
plastic plate from the microwave and you
gotta balance it
out you're like well this plate doesn't
have a groove in it [ __ ]
or you gotta like walk barefoot on the
porch and get 20 splinters or something
what the [ __ ] is that splinters so
you're going to suit for the house yeah
so she puts us on reddit to ask whether
or not she's the [ __ ] right and then
a redditor actually comments
she knew that her son would try to take
the money she left you it's very common
practice to leave one dollar when
disinheriting someone
so respect your grandmother's wishes and
don't give your father a dime the reason
your grandma gave him exactly one dollar
so that he couldn't contest it
that's so baller she gave it a specific
amount that's smart it's like when you
bid a dollar on price is right
it's not like oh so
you know that's a strategy i didn't
realize until i was like 25. i remember
being a kid i'm like this dumb idiot but
one dollar that's a [ __ ] family of
five to thailand like
four wheels um if you leave somebody
completely out it's easier to contest
than if you write something for them
like 50 because they know it wasn't an
oversight yes
[Music]
he was like my son's an [ __ ] one
dollar yeah explicitly being like no i i
thought about you and that's the
decision whoa wow yeah i think she
should [ __ ] follow grandma's wishes
that's that's what people do like if you
think someone's gofundme is [ __ ] you
just give them a dollar and then you
just so you can comment and say this is
[ __ ]
just kidding no one's ever done that
because i was like what if ten thousand
people give a dollar and they got funded
but then [ __ ] gofundme takes twenty
percent let's start a gofundme for you
for the one week of school that you
missed
sorry i brought it back i brought it
back for my eleven dollars per unit
get your tuition back yeah she was only
eleven bucks a unit community college in
the [ __ ] early two thousands and
that's so sweet yeah you should have got
the governor's fee waiver that shit's
free yeah that's what i got too dumb for
that that's a lot of paperwork i
couldn't even do it it's one page you
couldn't even read the schedule yeah i
thought spring break was a week ahead
wait uh that's a different video
i'm now i'm like what was your other
friend doing that went to school with
you his because well playing games
another side explanation but different
schools have different spring breaks
okay so his was on that week he was at a
different school i thought that at all
everyone had a spring break same time
because i'm a [ __ ] [ __ ] that went to
the same school my whole life yeah i
didn't realize it was different so and
that's why we're all in the arts bro
you